why do people have such an aversion to
the word sales because it it I think a
lot of people think that being sold to
is like being forced into something to a
certain degree like oh this guy's a
salesp person he's going to try and sell
me something and I think that that's why
there's that initial you know that
initial friction between what people
think and you know particularly that
whole kind of used car salesman snake
oil salesman that sort of type of thing
and the one thing that I I teach my
clients and my students in regards to
building a personal brand and a business
based around expertise is that you know
you just just be yourself just be
yourself if you're yourself you're not
going to come across a sleazy or salesy
you're going to come across someone
who's helpful who's got value in them
that's there to
serve